une petite schtroumpferie en me faisant
commençant par le volley-ball alors que
j'annonçais la boxe pourquoi je parle de
schtroumpfery parce que les Schtroumpfs
sont les invités d'antenne de midi avec
un Schtroumpf qui représente ce de ses
amis qui seront sur la scène du Zénith à
partir de ce soir et pour un moment nous
le souhaitons alors Jean-Claude Darrigo
assistait à la première de cette comédie
musicale on connaissait les Schtroumpfs
en bande dessinée en les connaissait sur
disques en les connaissait au cinéma
mais pas encore en comédie musicale et
bien nous allons voir ce que ça donne et
je suis sûr que les enfants vont être
ravis
que les petits enfants ne soient pas
trop déçus les Schtroumpfs qui vont les
faire rêver et piétiner d'émotions dans
quelques instants ça doit d'abord passer
par ce stade-là maquillage et
rembourrage pour ces comédiens en
qualités multiples et à la taille
limitée pas plus de 1m60 et parce qu'une
comédie musicale pour enfants c'est une
entreprise sérieuse et je trouve du
Zénith s'exprimeront avec le dernier cri
de la technique le micro HF personnel
au début le la première fois ils sont
pas aperçus que quand c'était mouillé ça
ne marchait plus alors maintenant on a
carrément de dans le nez on a du je sais
pas c'est une espèce de truc qui isole
pour empêcher la transpiration de tomber
sur le petit micro HF
le passage de l'album à la comédie
musicale est toujours un risque mais
pour les Schtroumpfs semble-t-il le
public a déjà dit oui
le petit plus c'est que les Schtroumpfs
dans ces chantent or bon dans la dans la
bande dessinée on les voit très bien
bouger le dessin de Peyo est très très
vif il est très vivant c'est plein de
vivacité ça on le sent très bien le
mouvement déjà et la parole et les mots
Schtroumpfs qui reviennent tout le temps
mais jamais on les a vu danser et
chanter
Les Schtroumpfs a dit un sociologue
c'est une méditation contemporaine sur
les mystères et les pièges de l'éternel
féminin au paradis terrestre mais dans
la Schtroumpf création le serpent on l'a
entendu s'appelle Gargamel pour les
enfants c'est eux qui font le travail en
fait et en plus ils connaissait le nom
de personnages que les suit d'arriver
mais c'est quelqu'un de Melou et ton
chat où est ton chat ça marche un peu
comme ça
et ben on y va
alors voilà ce que tu vas faire tu iras
dans la forêt et tu essaieras de
rencontrer un Schtroumpf moi personne ne
le saura allô pour me faire plaisir
c'est impossible c'est trop dangereux
vous êtes pas gentil je demanderai à
quelqu'un de plus gentil et plus
courageux voilà paillettes
les petits enfants tout va bien se
terminer et si l'important comme a dit
le baron de Coubertin c'est de
participer alors les Schtroumpfs sèchent